I'm thinking
maybe you and I could partner up
in a 2005 phone call between longtime
friends Vince Gilligan and Thomas
schnells they lamented their lack of
work following the end of The X-Files
the 90s sci-fi Mega hit they both worked
on snouse told Gilligan about an article
he read about mobile meth labs and the
two joked they should get in RV and
start their own business little did
either of them know how profound this
conversation would prove to be or how
the idea would actually end up paying
their bills
but I'm old meth lab that'd be the bomb
I mean
drive way out in the boonies
be all invasive
what inspired the pilot was a certain
amount of desperation on my part I had
been without work for a couple of years
when the idea for the pilot hit me I was
about to turn 40 years old and I was
thinking a lot about midlife crises and
was about to Embark upon one myself of
course Walter White is having the
world's worst midlife crisis which in
fact turns out to be an end-of-life
crisis one of the most critically
acclaimed shows ever made Brian Cranston
won an Emmy for best actor for his
performance in the pilot episode
Breaking Bad is a show that still draws
in viewers today it's been 15 years
since Breaking Bad premiered on January
20th 2008. why is it still so popular
and why would you want to revisit it in
this video we take a look at some of the
reasons why you should definitely
re-watch it and stay tuned to the end
for a special announcement
or Nebraska what's in Nebraska
you from now on
Breaking Bad changed what TV is capable
of and how we perceive TV for the
majority of its history TV shows and
sitcoms were self-contained half hour to
hour-long forays into highly predictable
and stable worlds while you may not know
exactly what Lucy and Ethel might get up
to in any given episode what kind of
case Perry Mason would be working on or
whether Ross and Rachel would make up
our breakup you can miss an episode or
in some cases an entire season and not
be lost when you tuned back in that's
because TV characters didn't change in
the plot of each episode generally
followed the exact same formula you
didn't have to devote your undivided
attention to each episode to ensure you
didn't miss a critical detail that might
be important in future episodes or
Seasons there were exceptions such as
the wire and The Sopranos but outside of
cable programming networks like HBO that
had big budgets and more creative
freedom you didn't really see characters
change French scholar Alexi pichard has
argued that television enjoyed a second
Golden Age starting in the 2000s with a
combination of three elements first an
improvement in both visual Aesthetics
and storytelling second an overall
homogeneity between cable and Network
series and third a tremendous popular
success not only did Breaking Bad break
the mold by introducing us to characters
who could change it also helped change
the way TV shows are filmed and consumed
Breaking Bad is Cinematic the second
golden age of Television Drew bigger
Talent not just movie stars but
directors writers editors and
cinematographers too for example John
told the cinematographer on the pilot
was the first person to win consecutive
Oscars in 1994 and 1995 for the movie's
Legend of the Fall and Braveheart he had
never done TV before he did this series
unlike most TV shows Breaking Bad was
not primarily shot on a sound stage in
Hollywood one of the most recognizable
features of the show is the stunning
backdrop of the New Mexico desert the
immersion into this landscape lends a
realism were more accustomed to seeing
on the big screen
who the hell are you
know
you all know exactly who I am
the higher production values were made
possible in part by the advances in
broadcasting and Technology the switch
from analog to digital in June 2009
required full power television stations
Nationwide to broadcast exclusively in a
digital format as a result
HDTVs became more popular the digital
Revolution coupled with higher
definition TVs created more cinematic
possibilities for small screen
production
it's uh it's got that thing where the
blacks are like you know really really
really black
Netflix began to transition away from
mailing out DVDs to the streaming that
we know them for now in 2007. right
before Breaking Bad hit the airwaves the
timing was perfect Netflix didn't have a
lot of original programming yet they
didn't get into scripted programs like
House of Cards until 2013. so their
Library consisted of films and TV shows
from other networks AMC was still
relatively new to original programming
and Breaking Bad had a modest viewership
in its first few seasons on air Netflix
helped to bring the show to viewers and
Breaking Bad remains one of the most
popular shows on the platform even with
competition from immensely popular shows
like stranger things and Squid games
viewers who first discovered Breaking
Bad on Netflix got to watch it in a
whole new way binging and commercial
free viewing approximates an experience
more akin to watching film in addition
to changes in technology much has
changed in the world since 2008 Breaking
Bad is a snapshot of middle class
America in the Yachts following the
aftermath of 9 11 and preceding the
socio-political crises of the modern era
set during the recession and housing
bubble crisis we can see how the
financial and social stressors placed on
Walter White and the other characters in
The Breaking Bad Universe shaped them
while not intentionally a show about
American culture Breaking Bad is a
Zeitgeist show that is representative of
its time watching it for the first time
in 2008 or even a few years later when
it first hit Netflix is a completely
different experience from watching it
with the hindsight of 2020 we are
currently in a global upheaval following
the kova 19 pandemic and the way we
perceive the world has changed since
Breaking Bad first aired for example
we've seen an opioid crisis the metoo
movement the legalization of marijuana
in many states Global shutdown and panic
recession inflation and War a lot has
happened in 15 years and watching it
with 2023 eyes is an entirely new
experience while our Universal
Consciousness may have shifted since
2008 some things remain unchanged
Breaking Bad is an incredibly well
written and enjoyable TV show there is a
huge payoff for paying close attention
when you watch this show Clues hidden in
the titles of a season and the clever
use of foreshadowing rewards viewers for
investing their time it is a smart
entertaining show with something for
everyone and one of those rare shows
adored by critics and viewers alike
foreign
the series received 58 Emmy Awards
nominations of which it won 16. it won
Outstanding Drama Series twice Brian
Cranston won the outstanding lead actor
award four times and Aaron Paul and a
gun both had wins along with a long list
of technical Awards including editing
directing writing and sound mixing
there are new things to discover each
time you re-watch like in a good book or
movie how many times have you watched
your favorite film should we only ever
watch our favorite show once it is
different every time we watch it well
then why should we do anything more than
once
should I just smoke this one cigarette
maybe we should only have sex once if
it's the same thing whoa no should we
just watch one sunset today there is a
seemingly impotent amount of content to
choose from across the streaming
platforms cable satellite internet and
On Demand if you ever get tired of
searching it's reassuring to know you
can always re-watch an episode of
Breaking Bad when you're overwhelmed by
the sheer amount of options or want to
return to a familiar world with the
conclusion of Better Call Saul in August
of 2022 we now have more answers and
deeper insights into the world and
characters Breaking Bad informs much of
how we viewed Better Call Saul and El
Camino did they change the way we
understand Breaking Bad
and that's why you should re-watch
Breaking Bad that and Vince Gilligan's
Walter White portrayed impeccably by
Brian Cranston all the characters and
actors are amazing but the show does
exist in Walt's orbit his story came
along at the right time his journey is
still relevant and interesting and when
you re-watch knowing how the story ends
you can better appreciate the way the
creators crafted his rise and fall you
might not get the same shock that you
got when you saw some of the series most
exciting moments for the first time but
you can gain a deeper appreciation for
how they were set up and why they work
so well this
is not meth
OD
and to celebrate the 15-year anniversary
of Breaking Bad we're excited to
announce we've teamed up to do a podcast
growth Decay transformation join me and
my co-host Courtney as we travel back in
time to 2008 to revisit one of the most
influential TV shows ever made we'll
have more information coming soon and in
the meantime be sure to follow us on
Twitter at Breaking Bad gdt we'll be
posting updates there and I'll leave a
link to that in the description please
like this video If you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already Go re-watch Breaking Bad and
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon
foreign